hey there doctor
i think the rest did you good
[Music]
revolution of the daleks latest episode
the festive special
new year's day special are a little
taste of the doctor in between series 12
and series 13 whenever the heck that
happens they still haven't said when in
the year that is going to
launch but in any case
okay so let me start with actually the
same thing that i said
on twitter this is the best episode that
chris chibnall has written
on his own for doctor who
now the question becomes how much of
that is meant
as an actual compliment how much of that
is a backhanded compliment
and it's a little of column a little of
column b but honestly
mostly that's sincere
that is a sincere compliment for me i
flat out
enjoyed this episode a lot there are
issues there are nickels a lot of it
just has to do
with things that i for lack of a better
term could have been tightened
and you know made more prevalent or
integrated a little bit better or made
more relevant
but there were very few things that
took me out of the moment and while i
was in the moment honestly
i had a huge smile on my face it was
sort of a thing that i kind of kept
stopping and doing like doing a little
check on myself and realizing
i'm smiling i'm smiling watching
this doctor again i'm smiling watching
her interact with jack i'm smiling
watching
her interact with me as i'm smiling
watching ryan come to the decision to
leave the tardis on his own oh my god we
haven't had somebody voluntarily leave
the tardis since
martha finally so
so many things in this just
made me smile and that honestly
is what i want to put first and foremost
because as i said
there's plenty of stuff that i can
nitpick and go like this
could have been a little bit more but my
overall thing
this was good this made me
look forward to series 13. certainly
more than the end of series 12 did
this makes me excited for more doctor
who again
and i was nervous going into this
because series 12 for the most part felt
like an improvement to me right up until
the timeless children because
oh god but overall i thought things were
headed in a good direction but that felt
again i still don't think
that it was as much of a detriment as
say hellbent was
to series nine i know some people
vehemently disagree with me on that
don't start that argument in those
comments i'm really sick of having it
but in any case i really did worry
that it was gonna note a general
downturn but
this brought me back and made me more
excited to find out
what's gonna happen next when we're
gonna get it and that
honestly is what i needed it to do more
than anything
and it accomplished that so let's get
into some of the specifics here
i actually rather like that the main
thing this is picking up on continuity
wise
is resolution which i'm gonna start
thinking of as a resolution of the
daleks because it's what it should
have been called but i i really
kind of like the idea of the
holiday specials whether they be new
year's day or christmas almost have they
their own ongoing continuity where one
is a sequel to the previous ones
not like completely detached from
everything else but like there was stuff
that went on there we'll pick back up on
it next year i don't know if that'll
continue into the future because things
felt a bit more thoroughly wrapped up
here but i thought they were pretty
thoroughly wrapped up in resolution so
what do i know
i i just like that as an idea i don't
know why
but i enjoyed the fact that that's what
it was picking up on
and i really liked a lot about the way
the daleks were used here i'm gonna kind
of jump around a bit
um i'm trying to think honestly what you
saw
already for me that's my spoiler free
overall i liked it
from here on in i'm going to talk
specifics which means spoilers
so that's your warning if you haven't
watched the thing yet
so some of the stuff i really like with
the daleks
i have been asking for years like
can we have a dalek civil war again
it's the kind of thing that we got a
taste of in remembrance of the dalai
lakes a little bit in
uh i think it's a revelation of the
daleks the
names bleed together sometimes but i
and i had hoped that maybe in the wake
of victory of the dogs we would head
there now
arguably this year isn't like a proper
civil war it's actually
seems like it's over kind of quick but
the idea of
infighting of factions in the daleks is
always something i've
liked and it's something that it feels
like the show has repeatedly introduced
but not done a ton with and arguably
this is even another case of that where
the idea is introduced
but then also resolved so maybe it's
another instance of like i wish you
would have kept that going but i'm still
happy to see it
i've wanted it for a while and i'm happy
to see it i
loved that the doctor's solution to
getting rid of these earthbound
clone daleks is to bring in the normal
daleks
and have them clean up the mess i
honestly
love that i think that's a terrific
solution
now like odd thing i kind of went out of
my way to avoid
getting into other people's criticisms
or compliments of the show
because i don't want too much of what i
say to be responsive to what other
people have said
i did notice some people bringing up the
idea like and the doctor commits
genocide like do you know how many times
the doctor has committed genocide
against the daleks
like the the show has basically given
itself
a blanket sort of like the daleks it's
different and that goes back into
classic era i mean what the heck did you
think was going on at the end of
remembrance of the daleks i mean
technically it wasn't genocide
in the idea that he didn't in theory
kill all of them but he blew up the
freaking planet this isn't new
and so unless you have previously taken
issue with
the 11th doctor blowing up the fleet or
rose um you know dissolving them
or any of these other things and as i
said even back
into the classic era then don't start
hammering onto whittaker's doctor
coming in and and having the ship
destroyed or whatever
okay again if you have or do complain
about every instance of this happening
and there's a lot of them fine
fair enough but don't be selective about
it the only thing
that i'll say is ultimately in hindsight
the show may have shot itself in the
foot slightly back in
uh series one episode dalek with the
whole the doctor
stopping himself well rose stopping him
from
destroying the one dalek and acting like
that was the right thing to do
because since then the show has been
like no we can totally destroy them so
that's about the one thing that i'll
grant you but again more often than not
the doctor
is totally okay with annihilating the
dialects on mass
so sort of what i meant when i said i
wish some things were tightened up a
really good example of that
is the social political commentary going
on in the thing
the connecting of the daleks to
police forces some of the things said by
the uh
new prime minister about security and
like it's felt very pointed at times
saying you know we will secure our
streets
our institutions our borders our
national monuments
as if like a statue is worth putting
a deadly tank to guard which
that's the kind of commentary that like
i'm here for
totally here for it but it could have
been tightened up in that
those moments and while i actually do
think that commentary is pretty well
done
and certainly worked for me um you know
liberal sjw that i
am but it's not completely
integrated into a lot of the other stuff
going on it doesn't feel totally
detached or at least not
to me because you know it ties into the
daleks and the daleks the sort of
insidiousness of
installing themselves and then basically
running a
running rampant and a rampage all over
the place it does all fit together
but the theming is not as cohesive so to
pull another example
my favorite episode during whitaker's
run so far has been
can you hear me which i know is an
episode not everyone likes but i
love and the main reason i love it is
everything in it
ties into the thematics it is so
thematically cohesive and tight i just
adore it
and that's not everyone's preference
some people prefer narrative cohesion
over thematic cohesion and honestly i
can go back and forth
i depends on the execution honestly if
you completely break the narrative for
the sake of the theming i may not go
with you but if you
like maybe this could have been tighter
but this is rock solid i'll probably
side with you which is kind of where i
land on can you hear me
but here that theming is not that tight
now it again it's not so loose that it's
a detriment i just kind of wish
that was that was a little bit more
integrated a little bit tighter
so tying into the idea of
socio-political theming should probably
talk about robertson
chris notes character now if you
remember
back when i talked about arachnids in
the uk
i hated him like a lot
the thing is though that didn't have as
much to do with the character and a
vacuum had a little bit to do with that
but it more had to do with the fact that
he had no business being there at all
he added nothing to the story of what
was going on in any way shape or form
so his that was a case where the
quote-unquote political commentary of
having what was very clearly
intended to be something of a trump
analog in that episode
had nothing to do with what else was
going on with it and didn't add to it
and was honestly distracting
here he does fit in more because he is
not the sole political satire element
because we have the over-policing we
have
the idea of sacrificing freedom for
security so we've got more political
themes and he doesn't stick out like a
sore thumb the way he did before
i also feel like they're not trying to
make him as much of a direct trump
analog or
at least that was the vibe that i got
he's still
that pompous american business jackass
that we
knew and hated before but it doesn't
feel
as much a case of see
look it's the guy mostly
there were a couple of moments where it
did dip into that
those did take me out of it but this
time they were moments as opposed to the
entire presence of the character
one was the line he has um berating
leo i believe it was his employee who
had cloned the dalek
and him saying see this is why people
don't like experts
and that line that felt unnatural
in the say in the dialogue and that felt
like ooh
because he's always going against
experts he being
real-life trump and that felt very
injected in and did not feel like a
natural part of that dialogue
and then there's the stuff that happens
at the end with them suggesting
him rebooting his presidential run
because honestly early on
the idea that what had happened in
arachnids in the uk had completely
derailed
his presidential ambitions that was an
idea i could get behind and knowing that
was part of why i was more comfortable
with him for the majority of this
episode
but then introducing that idea at the
end i'm like oh god i hope they don't do
that
here's the thing i very very much hope
since the guy clearly is meant to be
a bit of a parody of trump that now that
trump has lost the election
which this thing was shot well before
that had happened that they won't feel
the need to stick him in i wouldn't be
surprised if they set this up
so that if trump had been reelected they
could insert this guy as the american
president
and play with that
which is not something i think i would
have enjoyed in any case
and i'm hoping now that trump is not
getting a second term
that they won't feel the need to do that
even though they kind of set it up
oh another thing again i said i didn't
want to respond to other people's
complaints and i'm doing it anyway this
is going to be a very long very rambly
review
it's been a while since i've rambled on
this much about something so enjoy
if you do my voice is it grading i hope
not you're stuck with it
or you could click off now i'm really
tangenting anyways
so i saw some people sort of complain
that there seemed to be a lack of
resolution
on him or saying that well it feels like
they're setting him up for future stuff
and while it's possible they were
setting him up for future stuff
i didn't feel a lack of resolution
because tying into the fact that he is
such a trump parody the idea that he
wasn't
punished basically for betraying the
human race
more or less uh if you're gonna parody
trump
the fact that trump has really never
answered
for a lot of incredibly shady stuff that
he has done
on camera in public view repeatedly
and yet somehow it never sticks to him
yeah
yeah no that that ring is depressingly
true so while i'll
grant it from a narrative perspective
it's kind of unsatisfying from
a considering who the guy is meant to
evoke it's depressingly fitting
all right i spent way more time talking
about robertson than i had meant to
let's move on from that
so the doctor uh
opening with the doctor in the prison
both does and kind of doesn't work for
me
in in a vacuum in this episode i think
it works quite well
opening on her watching her routine i
like the idea that she's
saying hi to the security cameras good
morning camera37 good morning camera38
like
that felt good and felt just
appropriate and nice and i kind of dug
it uh again oh god like i
i really should have kept off twitter i
saw some people complaining about how
she couldn't escape a river could all
the time the main reason river could
escape was because the doctor helped her
you do realize that she wasn't escaping
the storm cage on her own and this is a
completely different prison anyway
so you know whatever um there was one
tiny moment that
yeah and people will probably and i'll
try not to dwell on this but like it did
make me oh for god's sake
so i loved it when at lights out the
doctor lays down
starts talking to herself and like do
you want a bedtime story doctor oh yes
doctor one of the classics i'm like oh
this is sweet
and then she started talking the opening
for the first harry potter book now
i did double check the timeline for the
production of this thing this was
written and mostly shot and probably
it was in post-production by the time
of jk rowling's essay
and while i'm not going to fault
completely the writing and the filming
of it i do
wish that in the edit they had cut it
honestly the moment still would have
played if say the knocking on the wall
that like snapped her out of telling the
story
if they had edited so that comes in
just before she starts reciting harry
potter
i i'm sorry at this point positive harry
potter references
are going to be a negative for me they
are they are
going to be going forward especially in
anything created in the wake
of this past july
that's that's my reality at this point
if you don't share it
whatever but that's that's where i'm at
she has
really developed a good chemistry with
most of the cast it's funny
and i think in some ways it was
deliberate she was kind of oddly distant
especially in series 11.
in terms of not really getting all that
close with the other characters and that
was actually kind of a detriment to me
because
and i've said the same thing about peter
davison i didn't feel like she had a
definitive relationship
and for me a big part of connecting with
the doctor is connecting
to the doctor's relationship with a
companion
because the doctor will open up to a
companion more than they might just
to the audience in general but she never
really had that
relationship at least not in series 11.
it started to get there in series 12
but here coming back and seeing these
people for them
10 months later for her decades later
i am feeling that bond stronger between
them and
i feel like it's reflected in the
chemistry between the characters and i
like seeing that was
part of what made me smile when they
were reunited
and she's got immediate terrific
chemistry
with jack oh jack's back
and jack's fun and i thought he was well
used i find it interesting that they
basically set him up to reconnect with
gwen cooper i have to wonder how many
people are now expecting some sort of
revival of torchwood
i'm not although it's possible chibnall
did work on torchwood quite a bit
so unlike say moffatt who had no
investment in torchwood
it would make more sense for chipnoll to
touch on it at the very least so
like it's possible but i would expect it
more as a possible
cameo for jack and or gwen uh
in future series of doctor who
i'm not expecting a torchwood revival
but i did still think that was kind of
nice and it was honestly
a smart way to not have
jack be a new companion which
look i'm not saying that wouldn't have
been great it would have but john
barrowman's a busy guy
and trying to wrangle him to schedule to
be the regular companion it probably
just wasn't gonna work
logistically so give taking that as a
given
because it is like logistically he can't
be the regular companion
they're never gonna get the schedule to
work
this was a i think a good way to have
him set up so that
he's around maybe we'll see him again
but he's not immediately traveling with
the doctor
um she had a lot of really good moments
in terms of her
intensity and actually i kind of like uh
how the episode drew attention to that
by having yaz
trying to be all intimidating at
robertson
and then actually saying when they kind
of get booted away by a security team
like
you know what it works so much better
when she does it i'm like
yeah no fair enough okay so let's talk
about the fam a bit
i like the way that
we get a sense of what they've been
doing for the past 10 months basically
that
well graham's just graham he's just
hanging out and he's fine
because he's a roll with things kind of
person ryan has basically made the
decision to move on and
yes can't and we get that so quickly
this was a good piece of really
um efficient storytelling
of them entering that house and it's
it's the other tardis and he has
made a freaking conspiracy board out of
it trying to figure out
how they can possibly find the doctor
again or thinking that the doctor left
them hints or clues
and has obviously been racking her brain
around this has been sleeping in this
tardis and it really
illustrates quickly and effectively
how different their processing of her
absence has been
and for me it works i had been
getting the vibe especially over the
course of series 12
of yaz kind of needing this a bit more
than the other two and i've said before
that if they were going to trim down the
companion cast what i want them to do
was have ryan and graham stay on earth
and have yaz be the remaining companion
because i thought
that was the relationship jazz and the
doctor that
there's more mileage to get out of in
terms of exploring it
now it is worth noting that in terms of
her
level of obsession maybe obsession but
the idea that she like really needs to
be with the doctor and even seems to be
trying to think like the doctor
that evokes a couple of past companions
mainly kind of a combination of rose and
clara
now given that rose i consider to be
kind of a middling character and clara
i have a litany of issues with one might
think that evoking either
or both of them might make me go oh dear
except that
like there is mileage to be gotten out
of
somebody whose relationship with the
doctor maybe isn't actually
good for them in the long run uh and
actually was one of the elements of
clara that did
start to work with me until hell bent
broke that notion in half or
rather overplayed it and broke my
interest in half
whatever i just freaking hell bent i
can't get away from dang thing
anyways i do still think there's some
interesting mileage to be gotten from
there and
it's been it's been long enough
since clara's been gone it's been three
full
series now including you know two with a
completely different doctor who never
interacted directly with clara that i'm
at a point where like this is a good
time to
re-explore some of those ideas which is
what i feel like they're setting things
up to do
now i mentioned already being really
happy that ryan made
the decision on his own to leave
thank you thank you so much and i also
actually really like that it happened in
the same
episode as jack sort of reiterating
something that drives me nuts about
modern doctor who the idea of
you don't get to choose when you start
stop traveling with the doctor and i'm
like
no you do it's just you people never
freaking do
other than martha it was driving me
crazy that the show kept
forcing the exits with companions
dying or being stuck in alternate
dimensions or having to have their
memories wiped
or being stuck in a different period of
time or whatever
i was really tired of this idea that
nobody would ever choose to exit a
relationship
with the doctor or decide that they were
done with their time in the tardis
i was really tired of that and so
it was a wonderful relief to me to see
ryan
make what really felt like a mature
motivated decision that was best for him
now graham tagging on to that at first i
was like i don't know
because he had seemed like excited to go
on more adventures
but then bradley walsh just did such a
good job
like delivering his line saying like
well i i want to be
here for you and with you you know to
ryan i'm like
yeah okay thanks to that performance
i buy that even though he was kind of
excited to go traveling again
when push comes to shove he's gonna stay
here
ending their thing with the bike and
like the vision
of grace it i found it a little
heavy-handed
a little overplaying the cards a little
bit
if it worked for you that's great it
didn't like kill the episode for me but
i was like that's
that's maybe a little too much if i had
one
thing like i've mentioned a couple
things like i wish were a little tighter
or i kind of wish this beat wasn't there
if there's one thing that made me go
wait um and
and i did think of this even while
watching it
i don't really understand why
the doctor brought robertson to osaka
like the guy has proven to be nothing
but trouble
why did you bring him and
narratively i understand why because of
what they intend to do with him later in
terms of him revealing to the daleks
that
the doctor is behind things and you know
just
him being the skuzz bucket that he is
his behavior tracks i just don't totally
buy why they brought him
to osaka and which allowed things to set
up to go to the next state i mean if the
main issue was we need the daleks to
find out it was the doctor there were
other ways to do it
and it just felt like a massive lapse in
judgment
that that man was on the tardis at any
point
so i i that's the one thing i was like
like you you had the characters
do something stupid because it moved the
story forward
which is always a frustrating thing
uh now thankfully that sort of thing
doesn't permeate the episode thank
goodness
but it does kind of show up there and it
did take me out of things a little bit
but again for the most part i did like
this i'm going to cite a couple of other
little specifics um just because i want
to be sure i get everything that i liked
out there
i actually really liked that little
moment again uh after
uh the fam kind of failed to properly
intimidate
uh robertson is they're walking away and
graham's just like
oh this is hard didn't it any notes you
know they don't have the tardis they
don't have the
um the psychic paper and basically
realizing
how much the doctor cheats
and they have to do things the hard way
like oh
man wish we had those cheat codes for
go anywhere i really loved yaz
saying please when she heard the tardis
noise like that
that was a great delivery like
everything about where she's at as a
character
and her need for this was in that line
reading
that was great i like the scene between
the doctor and ryan with him kind of
calling her out it does a good job of
setting up his
leaving but also like yeah look yaz is
so enamored with her other than saying
you were gone for a while
she's not gonna put the doctor's feet to
the fire that much somebody
should somebody should be calling out
the doctor generally speaking
um and that's not even specific to this
doctor like i really liked moments when
rory would call out
a matt smith's doctor because amy almost
never did
so that that was something i liked i
really like first of all i love the
visual
of all these daleks pouring into the
tardis
that was great and i think it was really
clever
both the doctor's solution in terms of
getting them into this backup tardis
that had a working chameleon circuit and
then getting rid of that backup target
that had a working chameleon circuit
because if the story didn't find a way
to get rid of that thing
then the question would have immediately
come up
why is she still going about in the one
that doesn't work properly as opposed to
the one that seems to have a lot more
functionality and obviously you could
have still justified it in terms of
um she's sentimental about her target
like makes sense but like it's easier
just to take a second tardis off the
board
so that was a good idea to not have that
thing still lingering around and i
thought it was a clever solution to the
immediate issue
i think that's all the specifics i
wanted to get in there again
on the whole i did like it now part of
me did wonder am i
grading this on a curve have my
expectations been
lowered because like i had a lot of
issues
with series 11. series 12 was better but
there were still definitely some
problems
am i just is this actually good
or am i just happy that there are fewer
problems than i've kind of gotten used
to under chibnall
but again i keep coming back to what i
said at the opening
i was smiling i wasn't just going
thankfully it's not that bad i was
actively enjoying it
i had fun and that is what i needed that
is what i
wanted from this that sense of fun
because that's why i'm here for doctor
who in the first place
to feel that youthful like
for something that i did not ever watch
as a kid
doctor who speaks to my inner child and
makes me feel like a kid again when it
is firing at its best
and it just makes me excited
and this episode tapped into that
not for the entire run time but for most
of it
it reminded me why i'm here and why i
love this show and i don't know what
more i could ask for
especially for one of the specials given
that the specials are usually something
i'm not all that
fond of in the first place i think this
was good
i think it was strong i think it it is a
solid indicator of
how things might feel in series 13. and
if it didn't work for you
i'm that i get it and i'm also sorry to
hear that but for me
i kind of needed this
i'm happy right now
revolution of the daleks
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about usual
stuff like share subscribe i have a
patreon
which is actually what pays my bills and
allows me to do this full time
and any amount you are able to support
me is greatly appreciated even if you're
not the other stuff that i mentioned
also helps me out as
well but you don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you're the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned happy new year
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you